as a federal employee i'm concerned with
biden's latest vaccine mandate
curious on your thoughts of threatening
people with joblessness myself included
to push a vaccine
we have arrived somewhere incredibly
dangerous because at the very least um
the right to coerce people and heather
and i may differ a little bit on this
but i i believe there is a right to
coerce people in the interest of public
health but i do not believe we have come
anywhere near the burden of
responsibility necessary before you even
contemplate coercing people in this way
right we for example
have not made people
safe from the corrupting influence of
corporations that
have a financial stake in whether we are
or are not
compelled
and so the point is until you're made
safe from the forces that might cause
this to be used in an illegitimate way
you don't get the right to coerce and
so anyway yes uh in in a different world
there might be a legitimate use of this
but wow is the standard high before you
reach the the place where you have a
right to contemplate such things and we
just haven't met it exactly um
i was going to try to find
um because we weren't going to talk
about this
i didn't queue it up and i can't find it
but
the guardian of all places
had a
article this morning
that was referring to research that is
still not
peer-reviewed and of course the research
itself does some hedging because that is
what we are obliged to do now
um but the guardian reports on some new
research in a preprint oh maybe that's
where it is
uh
oh here's the here's the actual preprint
this isn't the guardian article
sars kovi 2 mrna vaccination associated
myocarditis and children ages 12 to 17 a
stratified national database analysis
the conclusion of this research which
the guardian actually reports on is they
find that for boys between the ages of
12 to 17 the risks of the vaccine
outweigh the risks of coven
there's lots we don't know there's ways
they could be wrong but this is what
this research finds
and and the guardian actually reports
that
now the guardian is about as far
left
yeah i was like pseudo left something
whatever this is you know blue team yeah
but they're in the uk so labor team
something
um
i get that right yeah yeah um
as as is out there and
you know given these sorts of results
that even some of the most blue team
woke journalistic outfits are reporting
the idea of of
mandates when we clearly do not
do not understand the risks and there is
research showing that at least for some
populations
the risks outweigh the benefits
is um
isn't insane say
yeah now obviously there's no level of
caution that is enough for
emerging research like that but
we have talked extensively about the
question
you know why is it that we have not
publicly engaged the
age stratified risk profile so that we
can ask the question are we vaccinating
young people to protect old people and
does a rational society do that right
right um
yes
i mean obviously we do
obviously we would be vaccinating young
people to protect old people but if it
is not justified with respect to the
young people that we are vaccinating if
they are facing
uh substantial risks and the benefit is
recovered in the protection of the old
and infirm
i would argue that that is not a decent
thing to do that one thing that all
societies that are long-lived are going
to agree on is that the protection of
the young is their obligation yes right
we do not we do not rob the young of
health in order to award it to the old
that's right
my body my joyce slogan for no jab now
versus pro-choice in the past
thoughts so that's sort of a
telegraphically
posed question but um
i think i was never a fan of my body my
choice yeah as a slogan and i've and
i've said this places um it never it it
it's it's a libertarian conclusion and
um
i think an actual functioning society
that is honoring its commitments
to its citizens
has
has the right to expect some things in
return and i'm not saying that i know
where those boundaries are and i am
actively um and you know very much
pro-choice
um
but not because my body my choice yeah
it's not not not for that reason and so
i don't for me my body my choice um and
especially how it's being grabbed by
some people who are using it cynically
who never would have used it
um on the right for for no jab um i mean
there's there is something there there's
something in it that i think is
true but i but
but there's something about the framing
that doesn't quite work yeah i've always
disliked it and the reason is this we
know it can't be a very good formulation
because you can make exactly the same
argument for your house
my house my choice does that mean you
can beat your kids it sure doesn't right
and so the point is if the fact that
it's your thing doesn't mean
that logically you have a right to do
whatever you want there yeah but i mean
there's there's the individual is a real
thing
right
uh only sort of the boundaries are
fuzzier than we like to admit um
certainly you know at the ends and
right at the end points temporally
the boundaries are fuzzier and maybe
even spatially if you know using sort of
dawkins extended phenotype
idea
or you know other things the fact is we
now know that we are temporary
custodians of our genomes and that they
are modified and that our bad behavior
actually has consequences for people we
will never meet downstream of us for
example genetically how dare you right
epigenetically
epigenetically how dare you now that's a
shirt
but um yeah so there are those things
and also
when we've been incredibly clear about
this throughout the pandemic there's
also the fact that being reckless about
contagious disease does result in harms
that come to people who had no choice in
the matter so the point is
the formulation doesn't add up
but what has to be done
is we have to understand what would be
required to trigger the conclusion of
that formulation in this case or to fail
to trigger it and so
that that you know the obligations from
society from from government have not
been met right they have not they have
not been met and so the point i think i
think to the extent
that there's something valid in this
idea the idea is look
until you have done everything necessary
that you overcome all of the real and
substantial objections right
then we have to default to this other
thing which is you don't get to force me
yeah right you get to force me
when you have met the obligations that
you must in order that this actually is
not only in our collective interest but
it's in my interest i may be taking a
risk but that risk is worth taking right
and so
uh
having not met that this is sort of the
fallback position right absent absent
meeting the threshold that society would
have to meet its side of the contract
there is no contract and therefore
it would be my choice
yes good if you're not going to protect
me from economic corruption that would
affect the decision-making and the data
analysis on this point then it would
have to be my choice to say well then
i'm not going to participate
[Music]